but like the passion is the key
following the passion and knowing that
when you're in that energy state that is
where more probabilities and more
synchronicities come into our life you
know like that's why I know that when I
start doing these Live Events even if
it's not specifically the live events
that bring me like the abundance right
away it's me being in the energy state
of doing the live events that will
Propel me to be in a new energy to where
then I perceive of new synchronicities
in my life that I couldn't perceive of
before because before I was just in an
old energy state that brought me success
for five years but it's like it's not
bringing me the same energy anymore so I
need to change something and that's why
I know that if I just follow this carrot
on a stick of like doing Live Events
I'll figure it out as I go maybe that is
bigger thousand person plus live events
that are like using group energy and
stuff maybe it's more so I do live
events to get content that I put on
YouTube and that grows the virtual
audience you know I don't know but I'll
I know I'll figure it out out as I go
from just being in that state you know
yes yeah trusting the energy trusting
the direction that it's pulling you in
that it is going to serve the next
purpose yeah um I think one of the
things that uh I totally agree with all
that by the way is people are listening
and they might they I'm if they're still
with us I'm sure that they um they're
they're totally jiving with all this
stuff but
um whether it's the person listening
that might not completely get it or
whether it's someone that they know that
might need it like how what is it that
gets people you mentioned at the
beginning like 90 is awareness right
when people talk about being like
feeling like kind of overwhelmed or
frustrated or like there's a lot going
on and it's really difficult I'm like
you're so far much further along than
you realize the fact that you have
awareness to something you want to fix
yeah people spend people literally go
through entire lives without ever seeing
the thing that needs to get fixed and so
the fact that you come to an Awakening
or a realization that you want to change
something is already so much of the work
so the real question I have is like what
does it take to get that like what what
can is that something that could be
manipulated meaning like can you get
people to that state or are there like
signs that people should look out for
that would sort of be a hook into how
they can heal patterns heal relational
patterns heal ancestral patterns how do
people get into that space where they
can have the awareness because that to
me seems like it takes the longest I
mean yes the alchemization of energy to
grow and expand like here's the deal
lessons are always hard like as many
waves of it as I've gone through I'm
like this is so hard and and then you're
like [ __ ] it's because it's another
lesson and they're supposed to be hard
that's that's what it takes to get to to
to to shift it
um so how do we get people into
awareness uh the first thing I'll say is
everybody that is listening to this
right now now are so like already have
to give themselves credit because when
people are in the energy of like you
know consuming content that is about
this kind of stuff where it's we're
talking about awareness and
transformation and everything that you
share on your podcast they're already
ahead of a large percentage of the
planet not that we need to develop a
spiritual ego about it or anything but
like it is it is true like there are so
many people that are asleep and that are
just in their patterns and they're just
like completely kind of um immersed into
that to where they don't have they feel
like at least they don't have the
ability to like tap into that awareness
so if you're even able to perceive of
this episode right now then give
yourself credit because you are already
on the path if you know you're already
looking at yourself you're already uh on
the path of awareness and the key with
awareness that I found is awareness is
so simple it's just observation it's
observe serving what's happening in your
body it's it's observing what's
happening in the mind and the best way
that I've learned to do that is through
kind of what we're talking about earlier
where you take space like I'm taking
space for making YouTube videos that's
allowing me Clarity it's taking space
from life I think a lot of times we are
watching the news we're watching social
media we're consuming we're consuming
all these things that may not be having
the best effect on our vibration or our
energy and then we're staying in the
hamster wheel so to gain awareness it's
simply asking yourself new questions
like what am I passionate about what do
I believe about what's like happening
how do I feel about it and another thing
that I'll share that like has been a
something that I share on my Channel
that I I hear people reach back to me
all the time and say this thing changed
my life and it's so simple
um I call it I I learned it from my
shadow work integration coach that I had
a while ago and it's a very simple
embodiment practice I call it the frame
technique so I have like a video on
YouTube called the frame
it's a very simple process but it
literally is bringing the awareness into
the body and feeling the separation
between you and a like a candle flame or
you in the wall are you in the computer
right now if you bring the awareness
into your body
and you feel the separation between you
and another object or you and another
person if you have somebody that you're
you you have trouble setting boundaries
with other people
and you feel like maybe or maybe there's
like an X that you're you want to let go
of or something what you can do is bring
the awareness into the hands bring the
awareness into the feet and actually
focus on the separation between you and
this other person and and in the
spiritual Community there's this like
we're all connected let's all feel
connected but that is only one side of
the equation a lot of what spiritual
people need I believe is actually to
feel separation because in the
separation you're able to actually feel
safe in your own body and you're able to
delineate this is me and that is you and
even though we're all connected that's
where people get where they feel like
they're not able to tap into the
awareness is because they feel so pulled
into so many different directions like
what does my mom want me to do what is
my boyfriend girlfriend want me to do my
husband wife what does my kids want me
to do or they're trying to please
everybody and then you don't know who
the [ __ ] you are or for empaths or
highly sensitive people exactly and and
that's who that frame technique helps
the most is empaths it's people that
feel so connected to everybody else and
what that I found and I talk about you
know this is something I've learned from
my own life is that's being an empath I
believe is somewhat of a learned
mechanism that has been birthed because
of trying to get your own needs met so
for example growing up as a kid I was
someone like this because I had to like
in order to get the approval or
validation as a kid I had to tune to my
environment to feel safe so part of
being an empath is tuning to other
people and feeling like into what
they're feeling because then it's like
if I can make you happy or if I can
please you or let the tension go away
and avoid tension and you feel good then
I can feel good so it's a mechanism that
was learned as a kid to ease tension to
then get other people to feel a certain
way so then I could say oh now I can
feel safe and the problem with that
though is that then when you tune to
other people that often uh what ends up
happening is you lose your sense of self
you lose what I call your frame your
sense of frame and feeling safe in your
own frame and being able to set
boundaries with other people being able
to feel and live according to your own
values because as a people pleaser or an
empath you tune to other people and your
values become their values whatever they
value like I value that too and you're
like who the [ __ ] am I you know what do
I value what's important to me and
that's why I think it's very important
this whole frame technique uh process of
just bringing the awareness in your body
is then you could start saying like what
do I actually value in my life and what
I had to realize to shed that people
pleaser Persona is I valued as the old
version of me I valued validation and
approval from other people that were
like my top values I wasn't aware of it
but I became aware that oh wait I really
want people to like me I really want
people to like feel good around me and I
then became aware that I was living by
those values to get my inner childhood
needs met that where it meant of
validation and approval and then I
became aware of how much that was
actually hurting me I became aware that
in dating I was dating women where I
felt like I had to fix them or I had to
please them or and and then that was
making the masculine feminine energy
Dynamic not very grounded and that was
not good for the relationship and I
noticed that my dad my I got it from my
dad my dad's like a typical nice guy
that he attracted my ex-stepmom who was
a narcissist and that was the dynamic
that I saw
and so it's a trap that a lot of people
fall into unfortunately but yeah it was
uh I could see how it never as a nice
guy or a people pleaser you think if I
do this strategy I'm gonna get my needs
met but it actually doesn't really work
because people don't respect you and
then you feel like you're getting pulled
in different directions but I decided
instead of living according to
validation and approval I'm gonna live
according to the values of vulnerability
and authenticity and the thing with
vulnerability is that's the ability to
like show the real you so people please
there's an empaths are afraid of showing
their real emotions they're afraid of
being vulnerable they're afraid you know
back in the day I'd be afraid to like
show someone I was dating that I was
attracted to them and what I learned
after like this transformation is like I
now Express that I express that desire I
express my true emotions I don't hold it
back and it has a completely different
effect on masculine and energy masculine
feminine energy Dynamics and what I
realized is like that it takes
vulnerability to ask somebody out it
takes vulnerability to show your your
own emotions and to show how you really
feel and when someone says something you
don't like to like say hey I don't think
that was cool it takes vulnerability to
do that and the big the main wound of
the empath of the people pleaser is an
abandonment wound where they're afraid
other people are going to leave and the
way out of the abandonment wound is
actually into vulnerability it's into
being able to let go of the shame which
means I'm broken the shame is like
that's what people are hiding that have
that people pleaser nice guy persona
they're trying to hide the belief that
I'm broken but when you're able to show
the real you and live according to that
vulnerability it's it's uh it takes
courage but as you do it you start
rewiring your sense of beliefs of who
you are and your own sense of worthiness
and you start realizing you actually are
worthy and that's what changed my life
more than anything was valuing
vulnerability and authenticity over
validation and approval and becoming
aware of my own values what do I choose
to live by those values plus other
values
um following my passion and you know
things like that and that's completely
transformed my life but it's come
through feeling separation between me
and other people more than anything and
that's helped me feel safe in my frame
and it's completely changed like how I
show up it's completely changed my
masculine like how I show up in my in my
own energy
[Music]